whoa that's got some power oh no oh no
[Music]
we're here today in casota minnesota at
the drive a tank facility we just got
done two days of filming 30 total hours
and in order to wrap we have to do one
more thing
fire fully automatic weapons now most of
our crew has never fired fully automatic
weapons with the exception of sam and
nico i've never done it before really
looking forward to it and in addition i
heard a rumor that they have a barrett
50 cal they'll be on full auto main
thing we go in the range for about
safety so as long as everyone's safe we
have a good time i have an m4 but it's
semi-auto i expected to do something
like this
once so this is going to be completely
new to me i cannot even hear anything
have you ever shot me no no i have not
shot anything before and he said that i
they have a surprise for me so i have no
idea what it is
he washes the bullets away the m1 garand
is a 30 caliber semi-automatic rifle
that was the standard us service rifle
during world war ii and the korean war
it gained notoriety for its combat
effectiveness and signature ping sound
when ejecting an empty ammunition clip
have you ready go ahead no i'm not ready
step back on your right foot
now every time you pull the trigger it's
going to go up
look at that right in the center
look at that bull's-eye
dude that thing is loud
sounds so cool
there it is
wow
i've never held a gun before i just have
to say that maybe beginner's luck
good grouping that's pretty good for
first time shooter she's a natural
the air-cooled gas-operated m4 carbine
is a shorter and lighter variant of the
m16a2 assault rifle firing a 5-5-6-4-5
nato round it is known for its
versatility and ability to be configured
to suit any combat situation it is
currently one of the primary combat
rifles used by the us armed forces and
many other countries throughout the
globe alrighty whenever you are ready
go ahead and set that down there
perfect
that's pretty sweet
normally on a semi-auto you squeeze the
trigger and just like that this fire is
like at least two rounds every time you
squeeze yeah it's on full auto yeah and
so i didn't expect that i expected to
have to hold it down longer that was
really fun though i think i fired like
five at once that was the recoil it's
light i didn't want to blast the whole
magazine because that's just kind of
i don't know uncouth wake up
[Music]
that was great it's actually really easy
to control this is really my first time
firing a gun are you gonna burn it all
are you gonna i'm gonna take a couple
feel it and then i'll finish it off
all right whenever you're ready
holy crap
whoa that's got some power i've never
shot a rifle and that's insane
whoa thank you
do it all in one go yeah dude yeah
it's worth
it down
i'm gonna hang this up in my bedroom
that was amazing wow
david are you trying to get in there
that's just popping dude just desk
popping mags
i just desk pop for real
i've done this three times now wait a
minute there's four of us here
we don't have work to do today
no i'd much rather open up that box over
there oh yeah what's in that box red
what's in the box
i'm just going to say i think i know
what's in this box i think i know what's
in the spot
for what's in this box i have no idea
what's in this box so this is from a
company called cool wheel it's an
electric
device it's not an electric skateboard
it has two wheels
i'm just going to open this
these are electric roller blades if you
were to combine electric roller blades
with one wheels i love the highlighting
i rollerblade all the time i go down
market street in san francisco and weave
in and out of cars on rollerblades i'm
not even kidding dude i have been
waiting for this to show up for two
months okay this is really hard to get
out
okay
i am so ready for this
yeah so this is gonna operate just like
a one wheel okay doesn't even have
straps
no it doesn't have chairs okay let's get
on and go all right i'm gonna try it
this is
yeah i got [ __ ]
okay this is my first time on it
straight out of the box
okay i feel like i have enough
experience writing these things that i
can kind of know how to do it this is
going to take some learning oh my gosh
ham bone jar still applies
oh no oh no
okay
okay okay you got it okay okay okay okay
okay
hold on hold on guys
it's like the droid from star wars right
it is yes
[Music]
is it working here put your hand on my
shoulder
oh damn wow the future's gonna be dope
i cannot wait to oh what happened
i'm
inexperienced with this technology we
should have read maybe the instructions
yeah no dude okay you gotta balance it
either way here you got it you got it i
can't no my legs are not correct
there you go i'm inverted
what do you mean it's inverted this
isn't like when you you're working it's
working
you're doing it
it operates just like a hoverboard i
mean it's all just balance space you
lean forward it goes forward
nice yeah dude
that was loud
i love shooting weapons of all sorts of
varieties i'm a weapon owner i have a
bunch of modern ones i've never fired
any vintage one i'd let alone a vintage
fully automatic gun today i'm going to
finally have my dream shoot a vintage
fully automatic submachine gun what's
the actual model of this gun oh this is
a stand the sten is a british-made
submachine gun which was used in world
war ii and the korean war and is known
for its signature side-mounted magazine
it was created to meet demands for a
small easy to manufacture small arm
since the us-made thompson submachine
gun was an extremely short supply for
the british while amazingly cheap to
build it is generally unreliable and
inaccurate beyond 30 meters all right
you're gonna go pick it up you want to
make sure to keep your pinky in front of
this little tab there and again finger
out the trigger until you're ready to
shoot let me know when you're ready i'll
load you up copy
all righty go ahead and pick it up we
have an airsoft version of this that
we've used for a project or two but uh
this is a real thing look how small this
is
all you gotta do is pull the trigger all
right here we go
pull back let them all go
that feels so it's like a piston
that's like shooting at the fair
butter dude yeah so sick
which one are you going to do you want
to do you want to do this then too or do
you want to do the big before i'll start
with the stem
all you gotta do is pull that trigger
when you pull it to your back pull back
and pull it back all the way let them
all go all right
wow
wow
wow
hey
that's a lot of bulls eyes it didn't
have as much kick as i thought it would
no also you you were like basically like
prone there
basically you're like blanking on that
dude
the top half of my body
wow
that was great wow
double double heartbeat for sure double
heart rate
i've always wanted to shoot a 50 cal
anything but the barrett is like the
king of 50 kills
i saw that you saw that i got a round
off these are no joke the barrett m8250
cal is a recoil operated semi-automatic
anti-materiel rifle developed by the
american barrett firearms manufacturing
company with an 1800 meter effective
range it has distinguished itself as one
of the most formidable marksman rifles
on the modern battlefield the gun is fed
from a large detachable box magazine
holding up to 10 50 caliber rounds
any tips so it's a little safety here
i'm going to pick it up with your left
hand here put your shoulder up there
really lean against it your chief behind
that little pink stickers for the recoil
there's a manual safety here when you
get the fire just got to push that down
hear that click and then it is ready
ready whenever you're ready
it just kind of like takes over dude
cause i'll take it from here oh my gosh
honestly i think i feel like you shot
exactly the same spot almost exactly the
same spot look at that
shooting buddies buddy
just thinking that was gonna be like
that was gonna really hurt well they
have to recoil the face exactly
there's like a big spring behind it and
it takes it and then it like it thumbs
it off for you
yeah but you're
[Music]
oh
there dude
my teeth
[Laughter]
my head that was like a concussion
what hang over here
right
i think so i'm good but like oh my god
oh my god did you sure why are you going
you guys spent way too much time
together same spot where's my teeth
oh my teeth so cute dude you and i are
like in the same spot i get like wow
it's like
a little bit more a little bit more a
little bit more
like
i think we're getting better
collectively it's like group learning
yeah the hive mind has gotten better we
fired a sten we fired a fully auto m4 a
barrett 50 cal they were all really
awesome all really different the m4 very
precise and powerful the barrett just
overpowering op and the sten very fun in
my opinion simple
light rounds easy to control a great gun
that still works after 75 years
[Music]
oh that's a nice case thanks dude yeah i
got my
deck whoa yeah you haven't seen those
yet yeah those are crazy you gotta try
it dude your shoes bring dude oh
god dude
[Music]
oh no
like you gotta like crisscross
yeah damn right look at that
oh
this is way more dangerous
but it's a lot easier than the onewheel
depth dilemma right now
i'm in the pp pose
yeah when i got two feet trying to go
opposite directions i want to witness my
death here we go goodbye cruel world
[Music]
picked it right up look at that
man that reminds me of the time i said
look it seemed like riding the one with
like a pro look at see mike over here
riding the one wheel
[Music]
there's like a certain amount of junk to
them
i mean you just got to learn how to deal
with that jake was a roller blade
champion
okay i dare you to take them down hunter
street
why no one's done that yet i highly
doubt it's possible there's some rough
streets dude if you don't get all the
way down hunter street if you can go
touch the the janky stairs you know the
janky stairs the bump stairs
yeah those are there touch the bum
stairs from here five bucks what if i
can do it backwards then i'll be amazed
chips
chips if i go down
okay
but you can't fall once
[Music]
[Music]
all right go okay
no way we got the grand canyon coming up
here you got to be strategic about this
one
got
the real the real problem is going to be
the train tracks up here
close one
they call this section the highway
no way he's gonna make these tracks
i thought you were going down for sure
he's gonna make it he's getting cocky
two from stairs
oh [ __ ]
oh okay all right nowhere china yeah
these are kind of fun actually good work
man thanks
it's crazy they can actually handle the
mean streets five dollars mario yeah
please
all righty there you go mario thank
all right thank you